and all that thing about potential I was
tired of having potential I wanted to
have my now I'm an average ordinary mom
who said I want to drastically transform
my son's future the power of I am the
power of I am can pull you through the
darkest moment as you're creating
success create holistic success have a
small change over 30 days in a small
change over 30 days your breakthrough
comes will come in needlepoint moves at
some point I have to stop asking cannot
be great can I be brilliant
you have to disrupt that soil in order
to plant a new seed to grow a new fruit
there's not one line of business that
you can be in that a story and a great
story won't elevate your outcome wealth
is possessions and money abundance is a
360 experience I look at my life and I
wasn't supposed to be Who I am today
she's an author life coach and
motivational speaker she's the founder
and CEO of motivating the masses she's
also a best-selling author of six books
she's Lisa Nichols and here her top 10
rules for success I struggled off to
school the last time I took English
class I got to fail and my English
teacher said I was the weakest writer
she ever met in her entire life the last
time I took a speech class same here
I got a d-minus in speech and my speech
she should say at least a quote unquote
I recommend you never speak in public
that you get a desk job so that was the
beginning of my life that was the that
was my 19 year old experience and then I
go on and I'm trying to figure it out
trying to figure it out I was obedient I
went and got a job in accounting I was
in the collection department for seven
years y'all don't know I'm dangerous to
accounting I'm not just dangerous and
I'm in collections and you know you
should never put a broke person in
collections never because everybody's
reasons sound good to me funny but it
was real not only did I say girl don't
you worry about payin imma take your
name off the list
somebody went to jail because I was in
color I got fired from five different
jobs yeah and then I got pregnant with
my son unexpectedly and then at eight
months my son's father went to prison I
had to get on government assistance to
have my baby I was on WIC women infants
children to feed my child and when my
son was eight months old I went to the
ATM to get $20 out the bank because I
didn't have any pampers for him and in
order to get $20 out she got that $20 in
I had $11 in 42 cents and I still can't
tell the story without getting emotional
because of my story for two days I had
to wrap my son in a towel but something
happened Steve in those two days I was
at rock bottom I was broke and I was
broken Inglewood California my son
laying on his back at eight months I
have a towel over him and I have my hand
on his stomach fan
don't you worry jeylani mommy will never
be this broke again
and I made a decision I was bankrupt and
every stinking thinking I had I was
bankrupt and trying to protect my pride
I was bankrupt and trying to be all that
in a bag of chips and a bowl of grits
falsified I was bankrupt and trying to
not ask anyone for help I was
bankrupting everything that was holding
me and keeping me where I was I've
always talked a good game but I wasn't
doing anything with my gift and all that
thing about potential I was tired of
having potential I wanted to have my now
and I looked at that baby at eight
months and I said I want to transform
your life cuz you didn't ask to come
into this chaos well as an
african-american male child in South
Central Los Angeles with a single mother
whose father's in prison he had a 66%
chance of going to prison himself not on
my watch hmm not on my watch so if I
have to be willing to drastically
transform myself so that I can become
the woman that I know I can be right and
that's what I began to do I was radical
what did you do Lee so what what did you
do to change your life first
um I realize I couldn't grow
Oh with people who were struggling like
me that whole I don't want to leave
nobody behind no I don't want to stay
with y'all right you only but you don't
even want to be here okay I don't want
to be the queen of this block yeah and I
became okay with the fact that it
doesn't make me any less committed to my
community committed to my culture
committed to my family the best thing I
can do for you is not stay here with you
that's right when I've got that I went
to places I'd never seen before
I went to conferences where people talk
about money talking about prosperity
yeah talking about it was like no habla
espanol what y'all talking about
ro eyes and PPM's and term agreements
and capital dough fundraising and bottom
lines and what is that when I was i'ma
stay until I learned what you're talkin
about
I went to the same conference 42 times
and there I raised five hundred and
thirty-two thousand dollars in capital
for my company's start my dream and my
dream was to transform teen lives I want
to teach teens how to fall madly in love
with themselves and how to make
integrity based decisions and I got it
funded and I started working and that
was the beginning of me rescuing myself
I realized that I am my rescue no one
else is my rescue
so I was hungry like I was hungry people
often want to call me the exception like
oh my god you're the exception no I'm
not the exception I'm an average
ordinary woman who chose every day to
make one more extraordinary decision I'm
an average ordinary mom who said I want
to drastically transform my son's future
that he deserves to have every option
that every other child would have
irregardless of what he was born into I
just was crazy enough to believe that
that it doesn't matter the color of my
skin doesn't matter my religious
background doesn't matter my origin it
doesn't matter my mom's bank account my
dad's been coming I was born none of
that means my future that's just the
circumstance that I came from that's not
what defines my future I just believe
that not a lot validated it but faith is
believing in the unseen anyway so I have
enough faith to go I know like I know
like I know like I know I don't
necessarily have to see it yet Christy
talked about affirmations abundant
thinkers understand the power of I am
anything after the word I am is true to
your unconscious mind Michael anything
anything after I am anything anything
after I am even if you just you know
it's not true your conscious mind will
believe it anything after I am so the
use of affirmations is very intentional
and very consistent I was diagnosed as
clinically depressed and 2001 to 1998
I'm sorry I was diagnosed as clinically
depressed me didn't make sense I had
been in a relationship I was engaged to
get married and my fiancee who I did not
know at the time was bipolar and he
stopped taking his medicines and under
the belief system that love can cure
anything and so I ended up being picked
up and thrown three feet across the room
and I end up being choked until I passed
out and once I got out of that
relationship I just was different it was
different so my mom insisted that I go
to the doctor I went to the doctor and I
set on the table
and she checked me and talked to me and
came back in with a prescription and she
said Lisa you're clinically depressed
and I felt like I heard Charlie Brown's
parents talking like want want want want
want clinically depressed at least don't
that make sense in that same sentence
and she'd get handed me a prescription
and I read the description and had my
name on it and it said Prozac I thought
don't make sense Lisa Nichols that don't
make sense and I said do you mean I'm
sad she said very very sad I said can I
try something and I'm not I'm not
recommending you guys if you're a
medication you stop taking meds please
don't do that I asked my doctor she
agreed I said do you mind if I try
something before I take this she goes
yes but I need to see you back in 30
days if you're in the same condition I
need us to try this medicine I said okay
I could do that so I went home and every
day I got in the mirror and I drilled I
am every day because I realize I have
forgotten who I was
I just forgot I just and it was okay to
forget I just forgot so every day every
day for 25 minutes I just went over the
IMS every day I am I am I am and that I
parallel that with I forgive you for
then i parallel that when I commit to
you Lisa every single day I went back in
30 days and I'm talking to her and I'm
on fire she's just looking at me I'm
just talking talking she twisted her
head again and I'm just talking talking
she says wait I gotta stop you I said
what she goes what are you taking and
can I have some I was like I'm taking
some of me and so the power of I am the
power of I amp can pull you through the
darkest moment the power of I am success
is personally defined by everyone and as
you're creating success create holistic
success my bit my biggest successes are
the things that people don't even see
it's the fact that my 14 year old son
caused me his best friend to his friends
that's bigger that's bigger than any
book deal that you can give me that's
bigger than sitting across from Larry
King or beside Oprah that my 14 year old
son
cause me his best friend creating
holistic success is really important let
me tell you in order to have something
different you are going to have to do
something different in order to have
something more you have to do something
you haven't done yet I have to say the
things I didn't want to say do the
things I didn't feel like doing to have
the life I know I want it period period
and all I did was give instructions for
here do this bite size do this bite size
do this bite size bite-size digestible
palatable pieces of what you can do that
sound good you guys and when you look up
and you don't have to have a magnificent
change over 12 months have a small
change over 30 days in a small change
over 30 days your breakthrough comes
will come in needlepoint moves and you
look up look up in five years and not
recognize your life what's been your
biggest accomplishment you think
bouncing back number one is refusing to
listen to the negative shatter my own
head refusing to listen to other
people's perception of me creating
something from absolutely nothing so I
got a you know there's the books there's
the TV there's all that stuff but my
biggest accomplishment is being willing
to give myself a thousand second chances
and every time I got to 999 I press
reset yeah
I didn't ask permission I gave notice at
some point I have to stop asking can I
be great can I be brilliant can I be
okay and still be accepted I just
stopped asking permission and just gave
notice unapologetically not in a
braggadocious way not in a way that
shrunk anyone else in a way that said I
only got one life and i'ma ride this one
to the wheels fall off and then all the
other stuff came Wow as a result of a
decision I made right but it was a
decision it was a decision but it was
and it didn't come from you know a
motivational experience it didn't come
from an inspiring teacher it came from
hitting rock bottom there's so much
value in what you unlearn sometimes the
best thing you can do is unlearn some
things we're all always going after
learning something new because we're
information junkies because we have all
these forms of information coming at us
on the internet coming at us in books
coming at us on the
video coming at us in television that we
want to learn learn learn but sometimes
your biggest breakthrough is in what you
unlearn and then you relearn sometimes
you have to disrupt your soil pull your
soil up take that dry dirt that's been
planted for years I know I just been
knowing this for years is what my mother
taught me that's what we've always known
you have to disrupt that soil in order
to plant a new seed to grow a new fruit
yeah yeah you guys got that and so I
came very comfortably to disrupt your
soil like that's what I came for to
disrupt your soil not to necessarily
keep you comfortable what you know stay
comfortable that I want to disrupt you
in some things that are new awareness to
go oh wait hold on or new awareness
about what you've been doing based on
what you've known forever that doesn't
fit your future anymore because I can
guarantee you every single one of us who
want something different than what we're
getting we're doing something
unconsciously from all patterns that
doesn't even serve our future that's
when the tongue in your mouth and the
tongue in your shoe are going in two
totally different directions and your
job is to align them up so that you can
move forward in a powerful way every
single thing you touch is impacted by
your story as an attorney as a teacher
as an architect there's not one line of
business that you can be in that a story
and a great story won't elevate your
outcome every single line of business
every single line of service that you're
connected to will be impacted and
ideally elevate it by the level in which
you're willing to tell and share your
story so let me give you some guidelines
some parameters what I like to call the
bumper rails as if you're going bowling
you know when I go bowling I ask them to
put the little bumper rails down so I
can stick my ball can get down the lane
so let me set up some bumper rails for
you so that you understand what makes a
great story so one is the willingness to
take risk
most people vision when they're telling
a story they don't want to take a risk
so the story has it has its limits on
how high it'll go or how deep it ago and
when you have that then you're really
not at that part that's going to touch
my soul so being willing to take a risk
being clear and
concise with your stories a great story
is a ShowMe story not a tell me story
now this is the distinction that's the
game changer for most most people were
telling a story they say so let me just
share with you a little bit of my story
and I'll tell you and then I'll show you
so as I was building my life there was a
time in my life that was very difficult
it was very challenge true story very
difficult very challenging very
uncomfortable I didn't have a lot of
money I didn't have a lot of hope and
things just look dismal at some point I
had to turn my life around at some point
I made the decision that life had to get
better I'm telling you that it's decent
you learn about me then if I were to
show you that story I would say six days
a week I had to eat beanies and weenies
I had to find money in the crevices and
the corners of my couch so that I can
get my son milk there were times when my
heart would beat fast just that what am
I going to have tomorrow at some point I
got sick and tired of my own story is
this going to be my future no I can't
handle it notice the difference in that
second store oh I completely see that I
just painted a picture same story now
the second one when you show a story
it's going to require more of you it's
going to require to find the colors what
were you thinking what were you
experiencing what was going on in your
head instead of telling me you look for
money turn and point now this is
anywhere this is anywhere you are doing
anything I promise you you become a
great storyteller
and you will captivate your audience no
matter what you're doing I've captivated
investors
I've captivated students I've captivated
educators because I was willing to show
the story
I call it unpacking the story vision
being willing to tell me what were you
thinking what were you feeling
what were you saying think about a story
as an oral movie and so in an oral movie
think when you're looking at movie the
first thing they do is they identify
what state of time it is is a futuristic
is it in the now was it back in the day
you notice that based on what people are
wearing how they're talking so paint
that picture for me take me to that
environment set the backdrop up for me
show me what your
instead of saying I was angry you can
tell me you're angry but when you say
the hair on the back of my neck was
standing up I felt the fumes exiting my
nose I thought that my chest was going
to pop and I was going to say something
that I'd regret forever who you just
showed me you were angry take that extra
time to unpack it
why will most people not do that because
it requires a level of vulnerability
that we're not willing to share myth
number two is that abundance is
singularly focused on possessions and
money right that's what it's all about
what you drive what you live in how much
money you make when in fact this
couldn't be further from the truth
wealth is possessions and money
abundance is a 360 experience abundance
is a 360 experience true abundance true
abundance is your health because if you
don't have great health life does not
feel good abundance is relationship and
at the end of your life literally you
will measure the quality of your life by
the quality of the relationships you had
all the other stuff will fall the way
that promotion you're thinking about
you're wondering about that race it will
fall away an area of importance when you
get to the end of your life you will
begin to look at the quality of your
relationships how are your children
related to you how your siblings
relationship do you have love in your
life you literally will start looking at
relationships at a higher level as you
get older so when you mind them now
you take care of them and I know that
for a fact I have a friend who's who's
worth 14 billion dollars billion would
it be he was just partying at my house
all night long wouldn't leave 4 in the
morning go home and he flew in from
Canada to go to my New Year's party
because he loves my family connection
and he doesn't have one
he is financially wealthy he's
relationship broke that make sense
abundance is a 360 experience it's about
relationships it's about health it's
about your spiritual grounds that
doesn't mean you have a religious origin
it's about can you release can you
forgive can you let go
can you be still do you meditate
have time with yourself that has a lot
to do with the quality of your life that
ability
and I have a message for you a very
important message we live in a world
where you know limiting beliefs and
limited thinking is accepted and in some
environments is actually encouraged not
to put anyone down or any institution
down but look at our educational system
it's bound by who you can be who you can
be we're taught that you know as a
academic excellent student you were
expected to achieve more pressures but
yet even inside that more that higher
achievement there's still a limiting
belief there you know look at my life
today and it's barely recognizable I'm
grateful to say I have six bestsellers I
set with Oprah with Larry King on CNN
Good Day LA I've traveled all over the
world that work in Taipei in Africa and
Kazakhstan but that wasn't where I
started I started struggling or twelve
years in the educational system not
thinking I was good enough the word fail
are not passed was threaded through
every year in school in some area or
another and so I graduated or got out I
mean I graduated but what did I graduate
to I graduated more of who - more of who
I think I might be able to be or who I
couldn't be but not my possibility I
look up and for the first 10 15 years of
my adulthood
Ruggles I struggled because I didn't
dream big enough at that time I didn't
know I felt like my dreams were covered
and smothered with the cultural
limitations
we're defined by who our parents were
what our culture can do what our
community can do so you look at all the
areas of our lives financially mentally
emotionally family geographically and
all of those things kind of put us in a
box some of our boxes are this big so we
think they're amazing some of them are
this big and we know they're choking the
life out of us the reality is were
trained to be realistic to be logical to
stay practical and there's nothing
realistic and logical about Steve Jobs
in his journey
there's nothing realistic 'el and
logical about dr. Martin Luther King and
his willingness to be radical for a
change that none of us saw coming
there's nothing realistic about Nelson
Mandela leaving prison after 27 years
and leading the largest forgiveness
movement ever
there's nothing realistic and logical
about even my journey born and raised in
South Central Los Angeles having three
bites a week just to get home from
school you know being told that I was
the weakest writer my teacher had ever
met and that I should never speak in
public by my speech teacher - looking at
my life today and going on and having a
child before I got married and getting
on government's assistance just to feed
my baby not having money to buy in
pampers
and wrapping my son in a towel for three
days until I can afford to get money to
buy pampers I look at my life and I
wasn't supposed to be Who I am today
something turned but it didn't come from
outside it didn't come from my culture
or my my community it came from within
who I was committed to transforming my
life into just didn't fit it didn't fit
realistic it didn't fit practical and it
didn't fit logical I didn't know how I
was going to get there there were no
examples of how I would get there there
was no instructions there was no GPS and
there wasn't even anyone around me that
had an idea of how to help me all there
was was my intuition my internal GPS my
internal gob placement system and the
wheel and the desire and the big dream
inside my belly and I was willing to
keep at it until I burst something
greater than myself in order to live the
life you love and love the life you live
you have to be willing to step on the
other side of normal on the other side
of where people give you permission to
step you have to be willing step on the
other side of realistic you have to be
willing to dream big and give yourself a
radical chance for a radical future
and a breathtaking possibility it starts
with you I promise
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Charmaine
Robinson asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know which of Lisa's top 10 rules hit
you the hardest had the biggest impact
on you leave it in the comments and I'll
join the discussion thank you so much
for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon
you won't ever attract
money to you until you become even
greater steward of the money that you
have that when you mind your pennies
dollars will flow but if you are
currently not the best steward of the
money that you have meaning you spend it
fast you give it away you don't know how
much you have then it's difficult for
the universe to give you more of what
you're not taking respect and the
highest level of responsibility around
that's the ouch but it's the truth like
I kept wanting to make more money but I
wasn't minding the money I was making
right and when I begin to mind because
my money my mother used to say money
burns her pockets so I thought money was
hot and I had to spend it fast and once
I learned how to mine my existing money
all of a sudden I began to have space to
attract more money in my space so being
a good steward of your existing dollars
are very very important because that
will bring about more more more
prosperity you have to recognize and
this is a part of people resist they
come to me for help all the time ok
great let's find out what's then break
down I'm cool I just need to get better
you know something's and breakdown a
breakdown doesn't mean you need a white
jacking you on the floor it means
something in my life isn't the exact way
I want it we always have breakdown it's
just how we manage our breakdown so the
number one thing is to be authentic and
transparent about what's not working
even in your grandeur some may working
right you know I think the reality is
somebody lost 40 pounds and I found it
and I'm trying to return it to its
rightful owner
I'm just saying so that's what I'm
working on right now the best thing I
can do is be honest out loud about it we
try to protect and hi too much we try to
defend and protect too much we live
improving so first thing I get them to
us is what are you hiding protecting
proving are defending let's identify
that now what's the distance between
that and where you want to be and then
the rest is are you willing to do
something you've never done before most
people don't they want to have a grander
life a more exciting life doing exactly
what they were doing see my grandmother
said that conviction and comfort don't
live in the same block mmm if you're
gonna be convicted about something you
might have to go to some discomfort but
if you want to stay comfortable why
don't you just relax where you are cuz
that's where you gonna stay right and so
are you willing to reinvent who you are
are you willing to kill away the
procrastination are you willing to kill
away the excuses the blame game I never
let people to call me a single mom by my
title
I'm Lisa Nichols who happens to be a
single mother don't define me by my
circumstances define me by my intention
so it's just really being willing most
change will happen here first and if you
don't change there you can win the lotto
and still end up broke because I'm a
slingshot you gonna slingshot back to
your mental comfort zone most people do